burger scholar sessions with me george
moats
[Music]
sorry my name is george moats and
i love
hamburger history that's right we're
about to go on a historical lesson today
because we're going all the way back to
the turn of the century that's right 121
years ago
when louie's lunch in new haven
connecticut made one of the very first
hamburger sandwiches in america
ever luis lunch is one of the oldest
continually operating hamburger
restaurants in america for those
interested in hamburger history a trip
to louie's lunch to get an original
hamburger sandwich is an absolute must
it's one of the most important places in
the world not just for hamburgers but
just in american history they do claim
to have invented the hamburger
we'll get to that later but today
i get to live out one of my hamburger
fantasies you ready for this one oh look
at this my hair is starting up again
it's like electric
yo wow you feel that
ah that's right well it really is crazy
i get to do something that i don't think
anyone's ever tried or attempted before
today i'm going to attempt to faithfully
recreate the hamburger sandwich for
louie's lunch using similar historic
equipment and it starts
with this
[Music]
when it comes to recreating hamburger
history i do not cut corners period this
is a vertical broiler
custom built for me
by my good friend charles
if you've been to louie's lunch you've
seen the upright broilers that are the
centerpiece of the restaurant
the flames actually come at whatever
you're cooking from the sides
how is it possible
that this cooking method only exists in
one place still today in america no one
has ever tried to recreate the original
1898
broilers at louie's lunch until now
let's go behind the scenes and meet my
welder friend charles who made this
happen
[Music]
you believe this thing look at this it's
beautiful it's beautiful this thing is
beautiful
it's louise lunch i'm coming for you
[Music]
this is so cool
[Music]
the only way to make this happen was to
go to charles
thank you charles you're welcome george
anything for you you made it happen what
what just think it'll work what do you
think yeah
i don't know man
yeah i mean it's going to work the
question is is it going to burn down
your house
believe this so what we did was we found
the fish grilling basket
uh let's put the burger in and then we
have two portable
four cassette rooms
that's right
and you built this beautiful frame
with a perfect channel so we can put
this thing in here
so what was the big challenge here other
than not knowing what you were doing
like i'm usually making like tables and
stuff for people and not cooking
contraptions so that was like the
biggest thing i mean the thing that i'm
the most not sure about if it's going to
work is like the flame
yes the flame distance like it needs to
hold it upright
and close the flame but you don't want
to be so close to the flame that like
the burger is charred
right and then
you know
so hopefully it's going to work let's do
this
in a burger in here before
if it falls down then we're back to the
drawing board i think you just gotta
hammer your real oh all right all right
sorry i'm not a hamburger expert
look at that it looks like louie's lunch
yoo-hoo here we go
it's gonna be way too hot it's not
aluminum it's gonna be fine it's like
it's definitely gonna ruin that
oh my god it's actually working yeah
whoa
oh ow
don't touch your nose today it's very
hot i already have that oh it smells
good
yeah wow i just burnt my [ __ ] lips
so i think this is working perfectly
you had a [ __ ] i should get a nobel
prize this is it on the way oh hey
look at that god it's perfect here let
me give you a fork
wow
dude
look we cooked it
i'll be damned yeah it's not wrong
wow
wow
it totally worked
i did it
i'm pleasantly surprised
[Laughter]
louise lunch starts with a very lean
beef they use sirloin so we're going to
form a patty
give it some slapping
put this into
my salmon grill now because of this we
have this thing designed i gotta put it
towards the top right yeah up there okay
i'm gonna take a piece of onion
and put it in on the patty just like
that
and then close it up
see that the onion is inside the thing
see that
we got it all sandwiched in there and
into
our upright broiler it goes
[Music]
to cut
very exciting but while this is cooking
get rid of this but while this is
cooking i'm going to make some toast now
if you've been to louie's lunch they use
a
100 year old toaster i'm not kidding to
recreate that
i have a small camp
toaster
that will do the trick i'm pretty sure
very important remember that the
hamburger sandwich at louie's lunch
pre-dates the bun the classic hamburger
bun by over 20 years by two decades they
use toast and they've always used toast
they've never changed
okay i'm gonna check on the burger see
how it's doing here
it's cooking very slowly
so i'm going to crank up the heat a
little bit right anything
did this the other day
oh god hang on
houston we have a problem hey
that won't go up
see that oh [ __ ] what am i done here
oh i smell burning toast i'm burning
face ah jesus
is that working okay something's working
here
oh this is
becoming more difficult than i thought
oh you hear that
hear that sound
that's a problem
that's what that is [ __ ]
oh god oh god oh my god
oh [ __ ]
oh we're definitely going to sell the
smoke alarm today that's for sure oh
[ __ ] yeah so what's happening is the the
beef is rendering and the
the flames are igniting
and now i'm beginning to realize exactly
why louise lunch uses very lean meat
because you could have
a major problem oh [ __ ] doesn't smell
good either something's burning badly
[ __ ] look at this quiet
okay
okay getting there getting there
toast looks good whoo look at the toast
look at the toast
this stupid little camp thing worked
hang on
still adjusting
taking a look
we're good good look at that
we've got breaking news in the world of
hamburgers whoa what that's right
sometimes there's breaking news in the
world of hamburgers but not very often
but this is really big news
turns out
the claim
the hamburger being invented at louie's
lunch
has been debunked the origin story as
it's been told
is that apparently a guy rammed to
louie's lunch and didn't have time to
eat a hamburg steak on a plate with a
knife and a fork and he said put it on
some bread i gotta get out of here
and apparently that's what happened
but that's not how it happened
we know this because someone is insane
as me discovered an ad in a texas
newspaper
for a hamburger being served in a bar in
shiner texas in 1894 and it says very
clearly in print in this newspaper
hamburger steak sandwiches every day of
the week at barney's saloon in moulton
texas and as we know louie's lunch claim
to the hamburger sandwich is 1900.
i can't think of anything more damning
than that but who cares it doesn't
really take anything away from louie's
lunch because it still is unquestionably
the longest continually operating
hamburger restaurant in america period
we're on our way to recreating hamburger
history right here they realized they
couldn't put cheese on this thing
clearly
that would melt and make a complete
disaster of their upright broiler so
they started to use a processed cheese
spread
moment of truth
open this thing up get this open without
burning myself hey yeah oh god hang on
there it is
on to okay onto the toast only condiment
you can get other than cheese and onion
is a slice of tomato and i say slice i
mean literally one slice of tomato
another piece of toast where is it over
here here we go
they basically cut this in half just
like that
[Music]
and there you have it
the original
hamburger sandwich from louie's lunch
recreated faithfully with correct
equipment
with the right condiments
and the right historian
holy [ __ ]
oh wow
this is accurate that is literally as
accurate as it gets
wow
okay
i believe that my adventure
has come full circle this is a great
tasting hamburger
no
didn't do that we're gonna make a few
more of these
wow
the hamburger experience should be
memorable
this shouldn't be memorable because you
had too much flavor going on it should
be memorable because you know
it evoked
beef it evoked the american spirit it
evoked american ingenuity which you can
see right in front of you
it's exactly why i do what i do
here it is
i'll see you next time
when i go even deeper into hamburger
history
and i finish this jar of cheese
that's good
it's good
that's [ __ ] up
hi i'm george boats from burger scholar
sessions don't forget to like and
subscribe and watch more episodes right
here
somewhere here right here
up in here